giving burning long way hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to the
toy box now as you can see by these
lovely gentlemen or man and wife maybe
with their award-winning smiles we're in
for a bit of a duo [ __ ] hello I seem to
have dropped in on my spine oh oh oh
yeah baby
what the [ __ ] why was my vision get all
blinky walkie don't you dare I just got
in this you can't be [ __ ] with me oh
man this reminds me of that monkey game
the monkey with all the knives for him
and murder for brains Wow bad look up
okay I hear you I hear you snippy snippy
stumpy
[Music]
okay all right okay all right oh [ __ ]
dude is he behind me hi dude we're off
to a bad start here I'm about to lose my
goddamn mind okay all right okay
what the hell is walking hell oh god oh
god oh god
she's up season season season did I
break it what do I do
please tell me that was actually what I
was supposed to do and I wasn't supposed
to do tell me I didn't know I was doing
okay all right everybody calm down
everybody calm down not a big deal not a
big deal
everything's fine we got off to a bit of
a rocky start so everybody just calm
their collective tits and we'll get over
this so I think I think I'm about sorry
so what am I supposed to do I got all
your damn gems I got to find an exit
that's all right eBay Willie oh no
oh good great I found a door
let me just clap my own back [ __ ] why am
I supposed to do this
oh good water I don't know what that
does for me but is it purifying well to
get rid of the demon okay all right I
guess we're just gonna continue on our
gem collecting adventure get young good
thing put your wet you worship totally
agree okay only way oh they're getting
rookies held up by [ __ ] out okay all
right thanks I like tell them it's like
breath of the wild damn it
still tell them hey you were ready then
can you not do that that'd be great Oh
God
look there get some firemen I guess
you're into boys
damn it it's not going well for me when
I give you ten will you leave me alone
please no Johnny run - oh he is right
behind me okay Malik be back in battle
battle battle battle battle battle
battle middle battle two gems left I
don't know where these gems are god
dammit I don't know where he went
I see anything yes yes see this two gems
hiding around here somewhere
something me to find them oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] something me to find him I found
one as you estimate Lou here we go okay
alright then we're good we're good we're
good we're good we're good I didn't
break a dick I don't know why I'm doing
this why am I in these catacombs
it's like vanished or SCP please threw
me into the nothingness with the knife
monsters
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] me oh but not in that
order
BBD puffin a puppy oh it's the mother
lode no no no ma'am that was always to
drop my charm and good looks one out
okay so you don't want to mess with me
you've heard about me
I know markiplier alright professional
horror game player
Nona nutty circle don't mind my curtsy
fancy boy crack good be burning long way
back
[ __ ] hell oh thanks you just popped
up and then popped away and you don't
need to I need to actually worry about
you staying and killing me no ma'am
[ __ ] that got me good I don't know why
it's spooky
alright look sighs again give it another
go oh good it starred me where I left
off then alright I get your recipe here
I was gonna clue okay we're not the
mother alone
I feel like I just default onto the same
path and never mind is different that's
different I'm an idiot I went back to
the beginning come out don't have yeah I
did I couldn't reproduce anybody dry
[Music]
all righty then
well that was scary try one more time
you're gonna kill me your giggle yeah
get your lap down all the way
aren't you here to play you ain't gonna
stay nice little madam let another story
entirely
okay god damn it I like once more I like
how it sounds like getting punched at
Mason
[Music]
laughing no no no sorry rock document
book right seems okay
nah [ __ ] you didn't even know you that
close to me get harder to go along and
they don't know would then I'm a
professional very simple you don't come
to the wonders loans when it god damn it
I came right back the mother lode I keep
getting back here I don't intend for
that you speak on me you think you can
speak on me I've learned from my mom I
know how to avoid monsters like you my
mother's love will protect me
[Music]
my mother global bridge okay okay here
we go
Seattle time for need a duel ha ha all
right okay all right okay well you guys
Rock you guys suck but anyway that's
toybox demo i haven't screamed my voice
out in a while
that was actually really intense so if
you guys want to play this for
yourselves I'll put a link in the
description below maybe there's more
levels because I don't think I met that
guy on the right so if you want to see
more on this let me know in comment
below as well and yes I will get back to
all the series that expose the event
here one shot the other one that I've
got brain world I'll get them all done
and more subnautica on the way very soon
thank you get a place for watching let
me know it's not down the comments below
and as always
in the next video by
[Music]